welcome to Berlin Germany's capital is
the third most often visited city in
Europe after London and Paris some
visitors liked it so much they decide to
return and live here like James
glazebrook and Zoe noble three years ago
they moved from London to coit spoke a
trendy Berlin district Berlin's the best
place for us to live because it has
everything I mean you can go out and
party at 3am or you can go and see some
amazing parks like Tia Garson or temple
half and and just see some beautiful
sites as well it feels very DIY people
kind of if if there's not a club that
they like going to they'll just make
their own and kind of create their own
culture James and Zoe report on their
life in their new home on their blog
uber Lynn
initially planned adjust for friends and
relatives in Britain today it gets
40,000 hits a month one of the couple's
favorite topics is the peculiarities of
the Berlin native they don't really care
what anyone else thinks about what
they're wearing they will go out wearing
pajamas and take that dog for a walk
which I've seen another typically Berlin
reputation is like the berliner
schnauzer so the fact that people here
are kind of seem rude but I think it's
not a rudeness is just like partly kind
of German directness James glazebrook
Zoe Noble and an Australian friend have
now published a book about the Germans
my favorite points from the book is
definitely that Germans are completely
fine with nudity we have friends who've
gone too sparse and they've not realized
that these are completely nude sparse
and I think it's great it's really great
that you know they can just go to a lake
and just get with one with nature the
idea of non-germans approaching the
country by observing uncommented on its
residence is nothing new for years there
has been a boom in books that take on
German stereotypes that surely has to do
with the growing popularity of the
German capital more and more young
people from abroad are moving to Berlin
there are now at least 40,000 expats
from english-speaking countries in the
city there's even a thriving expat scene
with its own cafes and clubs some
newcomers organize themselves on online
forums there are cultural magazines by
and for expats English language book
shops and even an annual cultural
festival organised by the newcomers I
come from France I'm staying here for a
year and I want to stay longer I'm from
Scotland I've been here about three and
a half years I wanted to come and stay
for 90 days on a tourist visa and learn
a little bit of German and just really
liked it here and decided to stay like
you have the benefits of being a big
city there's so much going on but it's
not got like the crazy rush that you
have in London or in New York it's
burning you're living in the you're
living in the time it's where things are
happening at the moment it's not in any
other place in Europe here there is
enough space to be and to do whatever
you want
the new arrivals have a tight network
and often live in a bubble without much
contact with native Berliners many of
them don't even speak German certain
areas in english is actually the most
common language which is why you get
places like this where the staff are
mostly Australian and speak English to
each other all the time because you do
hear English Australian Swedish rather
than German which is weird and but when
you step outside the doors I mean we're
in oh can you step outside and you're
instantly back into Germany James
glazebrook and Zoe noble have resolved
to make learning German their top
priority they even like Berlin so much
they're thinking of staying for good